is it true that you one of your
toughest phone calls was of all that you
had to deal with
was about your pregnancy i was uh
i don't say eight weeks pregnant the
story i tell about being in buckingham
palace three days later the story breaks
about anthony being in communication
online with other women
and two days later i get a phone call
from my friend philippe he said this is
a very awkward conversation for me but
you know the new york times has called
and they're about to report that you're
pregnant and um
is there anything you want assured he
obviously didn't know and i was so mad i
had so much rage i felt like this deep
the secret i hadn't told anybody i told
we told our parents and our siblings and
so um he said do you want to you know do
you want to tell hillary do you want to
call people i said no i dare them i dare
them to run this story i'm not even 12
weeks pregnant and of course they did
and i was so shattered i was so broken
by not being able to share what for me
was a once in a lifetime gift yes that
till today today and i did it yesterday
in the kitchen that i wander around and
when i'm in the shower or shopping i'll
just say i'm pregnant
and i say it because i never got to say
it
before um
and yesterday jordan said to me mommy
you're pregnant
and i'm like no no no no and but it it
reminds you that there are things that
do stay with you i so appreciate
hearing that because it's not
always what you expect is the moment
here's what i mean
so when i got that phone call from chris
miller of
i got to tell you something something is
coming out
it wasn't the pregnancy i feared it was
being caught drinking
and i felt like
this was my shame
and i was almost relieved when it wasn't
that
when people find out your deepest
darkest secrets and i experienced that
when i was 13 years old
and got outed and thrown into an
institution and career over
i was i i have such ptsd from that
that i think if someone's gonna catch me
drinking again i'm gonna lose my career
i'm gonna lose my job that i love so
much
and it's so traumatizing and that was my
thing and it carries with it so much
shame
how did you
deal with that the first time anthony
and i sat down after his first you know
the first revelation about his
communication with women online
i felt and we went away we went to texas
to therapy i didn't understand anything
i didn't understand anything about you
know behavior that you couldn't control
i didn't understand addiction i didn't
know anybody growing up really who was
divorced or split up we these weren't
things you talked about in the middle
east
and i felt like the minute it was all
out he
seemed so relieved
he was like almost like an unburdening
and he said well how do i stop the
behavior and how do i fix it and i fully
believed he could knock it off 100
thought in 2011 when this first happened
he could just stop and then we learned
later when he ran for mayor of new york
city in 2013 when there was another
revelation that he clearly couldn't stop
it so every time i would get a call
whether it was from anthony or philippe
as we talked about everything there's a
call or a text saying this tabloid
called or i have to tell you something
it is how bad is it and and living
within this world of it's not going to
be as bad as i think it is it's going to
be worse because it always was
and
that's why in 2019 and i do share the
story in the book of really when i got
to the end of my i couldn't you know i
contemplated stepping off a subway
platform it was really my low of the low
and when i did that there were two
things that came really came to me is
number one
all of this holding everything and all
of this anger and bitterness was only
hurting me is something i later learned
with anthony in therapy is that while
pain might be necessary suffering is
optional
we have to go to another commercial
really quickly but we will be right back
[Music]